[Music]
I am dealing with some pretty serious
health issues since late 2015
low boss worth opening up about her
struggles with anxiety in a new blog
post on her site below down you'll
remember low from the hills I think it
was very nice to her though what I mean
now thirty low titles were new post 2016
the year of my great depression and
called it the worst year of her life for
the past you know 16 months I have not
been feeling right in the brain in my
body just kind of ill all of the time
what I was experiencing which was some
really bad depression and anxiety for a
really long period of time that really
crippled me the former reality star says
after extensive testing her doctor
suggested a very specific test and in
September they finally figured out what
was going on my vitamin tests came back
really bad like devastatingly low levels
of a couple things across the board my
doctor was surprised in her words you
know you have severe severe deficiencies
of vitamins b12 and D and those vitamins
affect mood and anxiety and depression
low showed her readers the numerous
vitamins G has a date for the rest of
her life and ended her blog writing
quote I'm living proof that you should
fight you should explore that you can
come out the other side with some
serious scars but feeling like a brand
new human being
you
[Music]